قالت السلطات المحليه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه استهدفت بلده لنترا توفكا بعده
صواريخ من نوعها هاي مارس ما ادى الى وقوع
اعداد كبيره من القتل والجرحى واضافت
السلطات وانفرقه الانقاذ تعمل في موقع
الاستهداف لانتشار الضحايا والناجين وفي
دنياز قالت السلطات المحليه المواليه ان
شخصين قتل واصيب 13 بينهم طفل نتيجه قصف
القوات الاوكرانيه مناطق سكنيه في المدينه
واضافت السلطات من القصف الاوكراني استاذه
مناطق سكنيه ومشاهده للبنيه التحتيه ودور
عباده اذا سلام اطلعنا على نتائج هذا
القصف الاوكراني على مناطق في في دونيسك
[موسيقى]
جلال نبدا من لجان في السلطات المحليه كما
ذكرت قالت انا بلده لندرات اوفقا تعرضت
لاستهداف بعده صواريخ بلده لندن توفكا تقع
على مسافه قريبه من مدينه اسباطوفو هي
التي تتعرض لقصف مكثف منذ ثلاثه ايام
بالصواريخ الهايمرز حسب ما تقول السلطات
المحليه في لوغانس لكن الضربه فجر هذا
اليوم يبدو انها استهدفت لنترا توب فرق
الانقاذ بحسب السلطات المحليه لا تزال
تعمل في المبنى الذي سقطت عليه على الاقل
ثلاثه صواريخ هاي مارس السلطات هناك تتحدث
عن وجود اعداد قالت انها كبيره من القتل
والجرح في صفوف المدنيين لكنها حتى الان
لم تعلن عن الاعداد المحدده للقتلى او
الجرحى تقول ان الفرق الدفاع المدني تحاول
انتشار وايضا ان جين من تحت انقاض المبنى
الذي يبدو انه انهار بشكل كامل بحسب
السلطات لكن هذه المعلومات تبقى اوليه
بانتظار تاكيدات رسميه من السلطات هناك
حول اعداد القتلى والجرحى وايضا الاماكن
التي طالها القصف بصواريخ هايمارس جلال
مقاطعه لجرانس تتعرض منذ اكثر من شهرين
ضربات المكثفه من الجانب الاوكراني
لجونسكو غالبيه مساحتها هي الواقعه تحت
السيطره الروسيه الاستهداف الاوكرانيه
لمناطق مقاطعه لوغانس بالصواريخ هايمارس
بشكل كبير فقط المناطق الحدوديه هي التي
تتعرض لقصف مدفعيا باقي مناطق لوكانس
تتعرض لقصف صاروخيا
بالهايمر حسب السلطات المحليه هذا في
لوكانس هنا في دنياك امس كان يوما قاسيا
تعرضت المدينه لقذف المكثف صاروخيا
ومدفعيه من الجانب الاوكراني السلطات هنا
تقول انه الاعنف على الاطلاق منذ عام 2014
سجل سقوط اكثر من 240 قذيفه تضرر اكثر من
50 منزلا وسته منشات للبنيه التحتيه بحسب
السلطات المحليه في هذه الاثناء جلال
محاور مدينه دمياط لا تزالوا مشتعله جنبا
وشمال وايضا غرب المدينه القتال لا يزال
مستمرا بين القوات الروسيه والقوات
الاخرانيه كما استلفنا قبل قليل بان
القوات الاوكرانيه او السلطات الاوكرانيه
تقول بانها رصدت اطلاق نحو 60 صاروخ من
طائرات استراتيجيه ومن اصول البحر الاسود
باتجاه مدن اوكرانيا هل من تصريحات اساسيه
مواكبه لهذه الوتيره المرتفعه من الهجمات
الروسيه على مدن اوكرانيه
جلال اي اعلان لاستهدافات خاصه يتم
استخدام القاذفات استراتيجيه ان كان ما
اعلنته السلطات
الاوكرانيه صحيحه هذا يعني ان روسيا
تستخدم قادفات استراتيجيه فوق البحر
الاسود وايضا يعني من مسافات بعيده تستهدف
البنيه التحتيه هذا الاعلان عاده يكون من
قبل وزاره الدفاع الروسيه التي تحدد
المناطق التي استهدفتها القوات الروسيه
وايضا الاسلحه التي تستخدمها القوات
الروسيه في هذه الاستهدافات حتى الان ليس
هناك من تصريحات واضحه بخصوص اي استهداف
جديد لكن روسيا دوما تقول وتكرر على لسان
مسؤليها انها لم تبدا باستهداف البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه هي فقط ترد على
الاستهدافات الاخرانيه وتذكر دوما بان
البنيه التحتيه الروسيه بحسب الرؤيه
الروسيه هي التي تعرضت بدايه لاستهدافات
الاوكرانيه وتستدل على ذلك باستهداف ج جسر
القدم في ااه كراتش القدم كما تعرف ضمتها
روسيا عام 2014 وتعتبرها جزءا من اراضيها
بالنسبه لموسكو استهداف هذا الجسر الحيوي
والذي تعتبره من ضمن البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه بالنسبه لروسيا كان بالنسبه
لموسكو هو اشاره البدايه بان اوكرانيا هي
التي بدات باستهداف البنيه التحتيه
وبالتالي ما تفعله بوسطه هي انها تقوم
بالرد على هذه الاستهدافات وتكرر موسكو
دوما بان مدن لوجان
همم مناطق اخرى من تلك الواقعه تحت
السيطره الروسيه او تلك التي ضمتها روسيا
الى اراضيها بموجب الاستفتاءات الاخيره
التي اجرتها همم تتعرض البنيه التحتيه في
هذه المناطق الاستهدفات اوكرانيه بشكل
يوميا دائم بحسب ما تقول موسكو والسلطات
المحليه ايضا ولهذا او لهذا تبرر موسكو
الرد بحسب قول انها ترد على الاستهدافات
الاوكرانيه يا جماعه